with alexey navalny behind bars the
russian state is now going after his
anti-corruption foundation
today starting the process of calling it
an extremist organization
we asked navalny's legal team if they
felt it was a foregone conclusion
but there's no escaping the fact that
this would deal a death blow to the
organization that navalny set up
labeling the valni's organization
extremists would put it in the same
category as
al qaeda or bizarrely in russia the
jehovah's witnesses
it would mean that the organizers and
supporters and this is a crowd-funded
organization
might be liable for long jail terms for
supposedly organizing
or financing extremist activity and
the whole process will be classified
because the state deems what navalny's
foundation
has been up to as a state secret
most of navalny's close allies have
already left the country
now campaigning from abroad for what
they call smart
a way voting backing the one candidate
with the best chance of beating
united russia the ruling party in
parliamentary elections this year
it's why some analysts think that alexei
navalny was targeted in the first place
he worked very very hard
to create groups in the regions small
groups of his supporters who
were trained to campaign to campaign for
candidates
who are running against the kremlin
candidates
one by one the state is coming after
those regional coordinators
this is alexei schwartz who runs the
navalny office in kolgan
arrested last week not for the first
time
his girlfriend tried to join him in the
car but it didn't work
in january schwartz published this
leaked audio recording of regional
officials discussing
how to fudge the numbers in last year's
constitutional vote
it speaks to the systematic vote rigging
that smart voting is up against
foreign
today the prosecutor ordered that the
activities of all navalny's regional
headquarters be suspended
his team from abroad say they have a
plan b
his teams in russia are extremely
vulnerable
dana magnay sky news moscow